welcome to the across the spoiliverse
podcast I'm your host X Change my name
gonna go everyone's gonna be definitely
on board with this they're gonna love it
and they're gonna start calling me X and
I can't wait to start it as always I'm
joined by Greg Alba from real rejects
Greg how's it going it's going well Elon
I am doing I am doing well uh admittedly
I'm gonna give this disclaimer up front
I just got back from Comic-Con yesterday
we had a panel thank you all who came
out and uh I am mentally and physically
still recovering from it
so I'm gonna do my best just to listen
to Paul today I'm going to be all of you
just thank you intently that's my job my
plan was to just talk all the time
anyway so yeah that works that works out
well with me his master plan has work
but you we were talking beforehand and
we got some topics to go over today uh
moments before he was like we should
talk about the Spider-Man 4 news and I
was like what are you talking about Paul
so there's Spider-Man 4 News uh
regarding the Toby Maguire one the Blue
Beetle box office and also Aquaman
Disney possibly selling apple and
Oppenheimer Barbie news and probably
talk a little bit spoiler talk uh about
Oppenheimer a movie that
quite made quite an impact so yeah
yeah I can tell you're pretty tired
because you've just said Disney selling
Apple just
like is selling Disney Apple Disney
aren't going into apples you know what I
mean it's not Snow White where they're
doing merchandise I appreciate you I'm
going to start my G fuel journey and
then halfway through I'm gonna be like
all right I'm ready to start the podcast
Paul but let's cook them to my G fuel
why don't we start this off with the
Spider-Man 4-1 since uh I could learn
about this in real time since I haven't
I don't know anything about it what's
going on on this story Paul yeah so
apparently Thomas Hayden Church AKA
Sandman he said that he said Sam Raimi
is working on Spider-Man 4 which whoa
pretty crazy if that's true it said it's
a rumor so you know it might be one of
those things where he comes out tomorrow
and says actually guys you know I I said
I'd heard it it wasn't actually true
it's been taken out of context that sort
of thing so by the time this podcast
releases might not be real but for the
moment I feel very excite I've been
thinking about it I think yeah live
action Miles Morales Toby Maguire
Spider-Man's the mentor would work
pretty well in my opinion that is a
great call okay so you're thinking that
this would not be the original he
wouldn't reprise or slightly rework the
original Spider-Man 4 story that
everyone has pretty much heard about by
this point with vulture and all that
um if you guys haven't it's pretty
awesome and there's also videos and
stuff that'll show you some of the
concept art that was put together he
wanted it to be his like most Ultimate
Spider-Man movie huh no pun intended if
he wanted it to be his epic Spider-Man
movie shirt to top Spider-Man 3 that was
a big part of it was a Redemption for
how Spider-Man 3 turned out but you're
hoping that if this does happen that it
would be a different story that wouldn't
be about him and Miles Morales
well just I mean the vulture story did
kind of get adapted into homecoming a
bit and I don't know if that would be a
kind of redo of it they might end up you
know getting that morbius post credit
scene and playing that off with the
vulture
um but personally I I think they should
kind of start afresh you know I mean how
many years has it been almost like 20
years maybe maybe less maybe more but um
imagine in that time Sam Ramey's had
more ideas and he thought you know
here's how I would do it differently if
I was gonna do it he's now working with
the MCU you know he's got a lot more
toys to play with and I can imagine Sony
would also be like can you not
incorporate this into something else
that's really successful too
so yeah lots of uh it might be debunked
already if it is we'll still leave this
in to to show you how stupid we are and
we've got we've proved we're idiots when
I well I have anyway when it comes to
the Barbie box office
um so yeah it might as well just leave
how wrong you are about that I love how
wrong you are
um that's the only thing you but you're
usually right Paul don't don't discreet
yourself too much you're usually right
on the money I mean we could end it with
the exact quote that uh Thomas said I
founded the exact quote Thomas hated
Church said was there's always some kind
of he's got that bottom lip thing
there's always some kind of I've heard
of rumors that Sam Remy was going to do
another Spider-Man movie with Toby
Maguire and if that happens I would
probably campaign to maybe at least do a
cameo okay so he didn't even like talk
with Sam Raimi about this you probably
read something on the Internet and was
like what's Twitter what's x what are
they saying yeah oh this must be true
it's on the www page so yeah that's
probably all it is
um I feel like there's actually reading
the quote now I'm like but there's
probably nothing too this even though it
would be cool if there was
well we've turned it in a clickbait
we've got the people watching but we've
also said it might not be true so wear
off the hook because uh everyone knows
if as long as when you do click bait you
say but it might not be true everyone
like you can't say so yeah the Blue
Beetle box office is the next topic very
very low
uh it's obviously still got time to you
know make an impression but you've got
to factor in the strike uh the actors
can't really promote it and so on the
opening box office prediction for Blue
Beetle is between 10 to 17 million
dollars
which can that be right that is so that
is so low it is it's so it's remarkably
low like remarkably low when I when I
hit it I was like that can't be right
that has to be because I've seen this a
couple of weeks ago on a on Reddit on
the box office thread and I thought you
know someone could have just made this
up but now official analysts are
reporting that it's gonna be that much
and
I keep saying it yeah if this does well
uh great I'm all for having Blue Beetle
as the first hero in the DCU but if it
does badly gun you just hard reboot it
mate Let It Go not gonna work you know
no one's excited about this universe
anymore no one cares about this
franchise just please please Let It Go
just just kill it I'll I like Blue
Beetle yeah I like them I like the actor
involved but please just just say sense
yeah I think what could help it
I don't know how much this would help it
what because
still kind of confusing
like I think most of us kind of
understand where James Gunn is going
with the whole DCU universe that he's
doing and he has said that Blue Beetle
will be the first character in the DCU
but the first official movie will be
Superman Legacy
and I think that if there was some kind
of language in terms of promotion
like let's just say for example I know
this is not what James Gunn is saying
let's say for example that the trailer
did say the start of the new DC Universe
you know the the new DC Universe begins
some trailer line like that that I think
that would make people a little bit more
inclined to check this out because where
Blue Beetle you know resides is still
it's still seemingly like he's part of a
of a universe that's no longer going to
matter anymore and well yeah yeah the
official the official tagline I'll put a
joke tweet out the other week explaining
it uh and people took it seriously but
I'll this is how I put it out
so everyone knows yet Blue Beetle is the
first hero of the DCU but Superman is
the first
DCU movie but the first movie released
by the DC Studios is gonna be Creature
Commandos very simple yeah yeah but when
you think about it all the other stuff
it's if it's got Peacemaker and if it's
got Waller in the DCU then it's still
connected to the DC EU so it's not
really the first DCU movie or the first
hero in the DCU because you've got all
these other Heroes who are coming across
from the DC EU who have already been set
up and they're now they're real first
heroes in the DCU before Blue Beetle I
can't even get it out myself you know
what I mean it's pretty messed up and
I'm just I'm James Gunn if you're
watching it I'm just saying you need to
hard reboot it need to draw a line in
the Sun and just be like look mate no
one cares about this stuff anymore or
that all the movies are bombing back to
back just you want to start the new
universe off on the best foot possible
look at what's been successful the
Batman Joker off in their own universe
first just start again please no one
cares about this old Universe anymore I
still care but the numbers aren't there
and the general audience they definitely
don't care I mean we just gotta look at
what's actually even doing well this
year alone I mean we're gonna go into it
later but you're just looking at the
movies that are actually financially
performing well you got to take a page
out of that now because the box office
trajectory has drastically it has
drastically changed but while we're on
the subject of DC Universe we should
talk about
Aquaman being delayed which did get a if
I'm going off memory here didn't it get
approved for a few more days of reshoots
from James Gunn like here's more money
to to add to the pile of burning cash
right now I think they said they
they got five days reshoots but they did
it in full I don't know what they were
shooting I don't know what they're
adding in might be post credit scenes or
something I don't know how much you can
get done in the space of five days but
apparently that's what they had they got
it done in full but now they're thinking
you know with their strikes going on
we're not going to be able to properly
promote this should we delay it to 2024
now this is something that they're also
thinking about doing with the color
purple and also June which with Aquaman
yeah at this point I feel they should
just drop it I I think if they don't you
know it's going to be a hangover into
the DCU it'll be next year and then
Superman Legacy is the air after and I
think I personally think it's gonna bomb
you know I have been wrong in the past
with stuff like Bobby but there doesn't
seem to be the hype for this movie that
there really needs to be you know you've
got controversial aspects with it as
well like Amber Heard we won't get into
that but you know do people even care
about the DCU to the point that they're
gonna go and see this especially after
all the bombs that they've had back to
back where the audience doesn't care
about this movie they did this entire
franchise personally I don't think
people are gonna be rushing to see it
it's been delayed a number of times
um it's even swap release orders with
the Flash and yeah
I just feel like they need to get it out
the way put it out at Christmas which is
it's you know it's release date
currently I think that's a good time to
release it you know there's not much of
the competition around it I think just
get it out it'll be okay and then we
start a new chapter we we take a year
away from DC a big break get people
excited again to see DC movies and then
you come in with Superman Legacy
well the first Aquaman did phenomenal
though didn't it hey I'm looking here it
made I made like over 800 million
International and I know that right now
we are struggling for Chinese audiences
to watch our movies our U.S America
movies but in the international
territory I think Aquaman the lost
kingdom would do because I think I think
people were surprised by just how well
it did and I think if the if the I think
it could have a bit of a avatar effect
you know
um I'm nowhere near the success of
avatar for I don't want that to be
misconstrued uh I think it could have a
bit of an avatar effect like let's say
that first trailer comes out and it is
is wow this is actually mind-blowing
look at this world that they have
created for for Aquaman too this looks
so much better than I thought I I want
to be a little bit more optimistic about
it however in this current moment in
time I am definitely on your on your
wave length of thinking about Aquaman 2
more than likely not doing well I wonder
how much they'll try to hide Amber Heard
in the marketing because whether or not
you're for her or against her I think it
would still be casting a a negative
Shadow just because you know the second
she's on screen it's just
people are going to act like she's in
every frame of the movie and it's just
going to overshadow like every every
talk online at least and yeah I wonder
if the if if the sex strike is over
actually it might be it would be better
so that way you don't have to worry
about you know
like the you remember when Ezra Miller
couldn't promote the Flash and that was
such a talk about it like Ezra Miller
can't talk about Ezra Miller can't talk
about now now she's just married so
she's not the the lead of it but they
would at least position themselves to an
excuse for you know ensuring Amber Heard
would not do any rounds of promotions
for the movie
yeah and it also makes you feel like
that they're planning on dragging this
strike out as much as possible if
they're thinking about delaying movies
and this came from variety as well which
are a pretty good pretty good source
with lots of contacts in the industry
and so they must be thinking like this
strike's gonna go on for a long time
which sucks
everyone's stay until the end of the
year at least that's what everyone is
saying that's crazy that I mean what's
up five months from now I know it's four
months yeah it's gonna feel long I mean
we're gonna have releases for a while
but then we're gonna then we're gonna
have this Gap where there's just nothing
you know there's there's going to be at
some point in time where there's going
to be like nothing coming out uh so I
think that's why they have to do the
delays uh so that way there's something
at least spreading because it's also a
fight for Cinema you know and that's
that's been a big part of the
controversy of this like yes we have to
support the writers we have to support
the actors undoubtedly that's the most
important thing out of all this uh the
the worry part though that we haven't
even really talked too much about is you
know like it's something that Tom Cruise
has been fighting for even with the sack
strike there was this thing that came
out about how Tom Cruise was trying to
at least position during the SAG strike
for the actors the stars of the movies
to at least be able to promote the films
because they're trying to make sure that
people are still going in the cinemas
well I think the Barbie Oppenheimer we
can proved that maybe that's not
entirely necessary uh regardless though
yeah it's gonna it's a bummer but the
fight must go on Paul what is the next
story that you really want to talk
what's what's the one you want to talk
about you want to talk about Disney
selling Apple you want to talk about
that one Disney are selling apples yeah
limited edition apples from Disney only
9.99
um yeah so Disney apparently this is uh
yeah apparently Bob iger's in talks with
the CEO of Apple to uh to sell the
entire company to him now this is I'm
reading a fan of wire here
phantomwire.com they're saying it's a
move that will shake up the
entertainment industry as CEO Bob Iger
is reportedly planning to sell the
company to Apple
the new user sends shockwave through the
industry with many analysts and
investors questioning the logic of the
deal now the report goes into what the
logic actually is and when you think
about it I when I first heard it I was a
bit like but then I started like reading
into it and you know Apple yeah they've
got a vast library of content and
they've also got a distribution Network
through not only you know apple plus I
don't know how many people will actually
watch it because I think once you get
the free trial and that stuff you're
kind of like oh I'll go with something
else but everyone's got iPhones
um iPads Apple Macs you know there's
lots of ways that they can push and sell
their services through Apple products
right and it would what fan and why are
basically saying is that if they did
this it would create a Powerhouse that
could dominate the streaming Wars as it
would allow Disney to accelerate its
transition to streaming
um and it would be basically just make
them have a monopoly over the entire
industry
and now yeah just skimming through this
report
um they're probably the apparently the
the streaming the company well Disney
streaming stuff is looking at an 800
million dollar loss at the moment
um in just its third quarter so they are
looking at like how can we recoup this
money and we have seen with Disney that
has been multiple losses uh pretty much
back to back recently with very few of
their films actually even breaking even
at the box office Kathleen Kennedy still
has a job somehow uh but yeah you know
lots of their films haven't done that
well and uh it's getting to that point
where it's like
you know how they're gonna sell it now I
I listen to a lot of different podcasts
um that go over this stuff and what
they're saying is that Disney they they
obviously when Bob Iger basically made
his name buying successful products so
Star Wars Marvel
um Pixar I think as well there are
massive things but now they've actually
all dropped in value so Disney's lost
money because they've bought it for like
five billion dollars or whatever and
it's now worth two billion or something
um so now they're looking at other
avenues to to get rid of this and get
selling some apples moving to the Apple
business
um how much would they sell it for
don't know I'm looking through this
figure yeah so much money though you
know yeah and it depends as well
Apple probably would yeah yeah all right
I gotta I got a bullet point break down
here can I can I share my one piece of
homework that I did I hear I I got
bullet I got a quick
all right here here it is this quick
bullet point of the pros okay
I got four sentences here of the pros
create a massive media entity with
global reach and huge Content Library
that's Uno two they could speed up
Disney's transition to streaming help
Disney's struggling streaming business
and then here's a big one increase
Disney's presence in China where apple
is already established that's a big part
and now the downsides got a quick
sentences here Paul downsides potential
higher prices for customers due to
increased Market power
possible job losses at the companies
merge their operations which is just
what Disney would want more unemployment
an impression that Disney is giving up
on its own streaming business I mean
well yeah a merger of this size might
face legal hurdles and needs approval
from the U.S federal regulators
of course and this deal would have a
huge impact on the entertainment
industry if it does happen I don't know
that could be a pro or a con so it seems
like there's pros and cons I have heard
that they're just planning on selling
because there's like subsidiaries of
Disney plus like it's a different name
in India or something like that like I
don't really know but I've heard please
correct me in the comments that they
could be just selling the the four
inside instead of the the US side uh but
in England we've got star instead of
Hulu gotcha so we're going to Disney
plus you click your store it's got your
Walking Dead it's got your bear on it's
got all the the dirty stuff that won't
show on Disney but it's just on Disney
plus yeah um so yeah I'm guessing it's
I'm sure it's hot star in some countries
um but I'm just looking at Apple's
company with 3.3 trillion so you know
yeah and I'm just thinking about it I
said earlier you know no one really
watches apple plus
but if they build it into Disney plus
you know what I mean they have all the
shows on one big streaming service that
people are going to start watching it
um because so I I you know it makes
sense obviously you know Bob Iger is
pulling from the David zaz love handbook
I've just got the company sell off as
much as you can get your bonus and then
off so yeah we'll uh we'll see how
that goes I think it would take them so
long to make a profit though remember it
was like it took like Netflix 10 years
or something like that to truly make a
profit and I think it would take a long
time to make a profit yeah
they're not Kettle will be dead by then
but and in 50 years time there'll be
YouTube documentary so like and genius
Bob Iger made it groundbreaking deal in
selling Disney off to Apple and it
changed the world and we all became
slaves that just constantly couldn't
escape the corporation that had
infiltrated all aspects of Our Lives
uh so yeah he's a dick
um tells his Bob bagger we should talk
about Oppenheimer yeah the thumbnail for
this was broke the rules because we're
playing a bit of stuff yeah we're saying
how you know Bob I guess kind of
breaking the rules selling Disney off
the Apple but Bob and Heimer it's also
broken the rules because what were the
rules three months ago comic book movies
that make loads of money let's do as
many comic book movies as we can they
don't stop we just a license to print
money they don't stop making money and
then as we've seen they don't make that
much but Barbie in Oppenheimer too you
know people keep saying Barbies like an
original Ip but it's like well it's been
around 50 years I think Barbie's
household name at this point but you
know hasn't had a movie at this point
um and Oppenheimer is obviously a three
hour long historical documentary R-rated
shot purely for cinephiles in 70
millimeter RI Max but it's doing really
well and both of them are doing great
again apologies for being such an idiot
and saying that uh Barbie would flop but
you know
I'm not exactly a box office analyst
guys apologies I know I'll go on about
it every weekend
you've caught me out again but yeah so
uh they've done really really well you
know hats after them
um I think it was a genius marketing
push to kind of you know take these two
films that were competing with each
other the two opposite ends of the
Spectrum Entertainment wise and just
turning it into this almost cultural
event of
um you know like they made it into this
now I didn't go see them both I only
went to see Oppenheimer but I know my my
editors they were getting t-shirts going
out to see them celebrating this big
event and lots of people I know went to
one and then went immediately together
or someone on a Friday and then went to
see the other on a Saturday and they tin
in this big event and going to the
cinema around here
absolutely packed yeah packed from 9am
on the Friday and like my editors were
messaging me like 11 p.m on the Saturday
being like this it's it's completely
rammed completely rammed my in in uh
that was like Comic-Con and my my wife
went with my mom and sister to go watch
it at one of the most popular theaters
out here in LA
and five minutes before and the theater
was actually being reported on and and
she she was there at the screening when
this happened five minutes before her
showing of Barbie ended like it was like
towards the the ending uh the this alarm
started going off and everyone had to
evacuate the theater and it turned to
like this crazy mess where it was just
like jam-packed on the escalators and
security had to get involved and then
they eventually a couple hours later
allowed people in back into the theater
but then the air conditioning wasn't
working and so then they had to try to
some people were trying to get refunds
some people just powered through
regardless I feel like I haven't seen
Barbie yet
um because I was away this weekend
but I've seen Oppenheimer and
have you talked to anyone who saw both
in the same day I feel like that'd be
such a terrible idea they they're
they're so drastically different that I
think what you would watch prior because
you know you kind of like especially
like a movie like Oppenheimer or even
Barbie whichever great things about
obviously that you would kind of need to
settle with you might need yourself with
Oppenheimer longer than you would with
Barbie that's just my guess I have no
idea I just feel like watching both back
to back would make you whatever the
latter one is that you watch would make
it harder to appreciate that one I think
just because of how different that is
like I was seeing tick tocks of people
who literally finished Barbie and are
rushing to Oppenheimer right when the
universal logo is happening and I just
think that's just I don't I don't think
I would want to do that to myself I
think it's funny and I thought that was
great marketing and I thought it was
cool that two separate Studios managed
to uplift each other to have successful
box offices at the same time I I don't
think I would ever do that I like watch
two drastically different movies back to
back like that did your editors or
anyone you know tell you about that yeah
I'm pretty sure my editor Matt he he did
them back to back he loved it oh he did
he actually loved it oh
he just loves being at the cinema hey
any film he goes to see he's like oh
it's the best film I've ever seen right
after it or it's the worst film I've
ever seen what did he watch first
he watched Oppenheimer first that's the
way that I was saying yeah three hours
of pure Cinema he said that was amazing
he said three hours felt like half an
hour and then just went straight in the
Barbie guy powered through lovely bloke
and he kept us right so I'm gonna read
out yeah some of the stats for uh for a
Barbie and I'm gonna shake my head
because I'm so angry I got it wrong so
Barbie accomplishments biggest domestic
opening of 2023 which I I remember
saying on the podcast and I didn't say
it would flop
um biggest opening ever for a female
director biggest opening for a movie
based on a toy biggest opening ever for
Margot Robbie and Ryan Gosling biggest
opening weekend for a movie that is in a
sequel remake or superhero movie so
completely killed it
idiot who said it would uh flop so yeah
it's a path of Lifetime grosses of other
females are you getting this from the
deadline article that's what I just
pulled up that uh yeah it surpassed the
lifetime grosses of many other female
lead movies it's kind of crazy that the
two biggest openings
um of this year are Mario
and Barbie uh of of the year which yeah
they're not superhero movies they're you
could obviously Mario is based on a
classic video game and Barbie's based on
a classic toy that's been but both have
been long lasting franchises and the
medium that they belong to prior to
transitioning to cinema and it's really
cool to see what they did and especially
for Barbie which I I hear is a bit of an
odd film but people really love it
people people love it a lot because I
get that thing you were saying of
everyone's like it's an original film
and and while it's based on an IP I've
heard the approach I've been trying to
avoid specifics because I want to watch
it and everyone's saying how good it is
I am hearing that it it is a very
original way of doing it where they
could have just had a safe alternative
route to it that they did take a very
original approach so I think that's
really cool how how well this movie's in
which just shows you man people just
want a good movie people want a re
original to even if you're doing it I
that's what we mean by the superhero
genre is that what people want is the
they just want an original take even if
it is a comic book movie find a way to
do it in original way that's why it's
like Joker did so well you know that's
why the Batman exceeded so well do you
want to go over the Oppenheimer facts
too at some point well just a little
comment on this uh you know for the last
couple of years who've been saying
what's going to happen when superhero
movies die and it's always been a case
of like well what happened after the
Westin died I think we're now living
through that period where superhero
movies they're not
correct they're not doing those crazy
guaranteed box office numbers that they
used to do and we're seeing you know
what's going to be the next stage and
we're transitioning from That Into You
know maybe things based on historical
events or already established IPS that
haven't been made into movies yet and
then we're watching them kind of play
out and I think that you know I've often
thought the next step after the comic
book movie was gonna be the good video
game movie and I thought it would be in
the same way that you know back you know
we had Superman and Batman which were
great but there was a long period where
a lot of comic book movies were
absolutely terrible like so bad and I
feel like that's something that happened
with video game movies as well and they
are starting to get it right they're
starting to figure out what works with
it and yeah I think that's going to be
the next stage and then alongside it
will have original IPS you know
I mean going back to the the 60s even
with the Westin if you look at what
happened the 60s was just like people
just kind of were getting bored of the
same thing happening over and over again
and there was not a massive crash but
movies just weren't pulling in what they
were and this the people are just doing
westerns to the death and then you know
there was a big transitional stage it
was actually a strike in the 60s as well
that changed a lot of things and then
after that came the 70s where we had
lots of
Auto directors
um Steven Spielberg came out Martin
Scorsese you know people with their own
original ideas that revitalized Cinema
things like The Godfather you know what
I mean they took things in a brand new
direction and you know we're kind of
seeing history repeat itself we're
getting a strike going into a
transitional period and then you know
the big comic book movie thing that's
been dominating everything you know
that's kind of dying off and what we're
seeing some creative stuff being done
and you know what it's good as well and
it's going to get people back in the
cinema they're excited to see it I think
that's why Blue Beetle is not tracking
well you know because it just
I think it looks it looks fun it does it
looks fun and a lot of times I'll see
comments on like when we cover trailers
for stuff whether it be the Marvels or
Blue Beetle I saw with Shazam Fury of
the Gods I saw with the flash is like
there's always the comments where people
are going all I want is a fun movie all
I want is a fun movie
and I don't think though I think you
know they they often I've heard the the
phrase of results is the name of the
game you know look at the numbers for
things and while of course there's that
audience out there like those comments
there is that audience that ultimately
just wants a fun movie and of course
that's the main thing I'd want to walk
away with is not the worst insult I
could give to a movie is that it's
boring so I just want it to be fun as
well however if we're talking about
movies where they're spending so much
like ridiculous amounts of money now and
they need to have and they have to like
struggle and really like like churn
their way to the freaking uh Break Even
line not even the profit line but just
the break even line
clearly settling for just a fun passable
movie is not the name of the game
anymore you know they need it to be
something that is
that feels original that does feel
special and I think that was
communicated too and and um with Barbie
and Oppenheimer did and plus they just
had brilliant marketing but like the I I
don't recall A Time In Our Lifetime
where we had two movies that
managed to help uplift each other edify
one another you know to this degree
because I think it really did help and
it's it's so cool to see for Just Two
drastically different films and how well
both of them did and especially for
Barbie because Oppenheimer
um took took up the the premium screens
you know like they the premium screens
were a lot like that's where a lot of
Oppenheimer made its money from was the
premium screens like IMAX and such and
for Barbie to not have that and still do
this well
is pretty freaking incredible I I'm
really happy for the film I can't I
can't wait to see it I think it's it's
really exciting and I'm happy for how
well it's doing without having them
premium screens yeah and going back to
what you said before the budgets on
superhero movies are absolutely crazy
like I don't know how they cost this
much Blue Beetle 120 million
um budget more than Oppenheimer yeah but
Barbie 145 million
um oppenheimer's said to be a hundred
million but they are kind of contesting
that but it's not much more expensive
even at its highest what you know its
highest estimate it's not much more
expensive than Blue Beetle and when that
blows my mind because of one how good it
looks
two it's a period piece so that's
expensive to do
and three the cast cast
not to slag off the Blue Beetle cast
yeah but if they're passing me in the
street I don't think I'd recognize them
if anyone from the Oppenheimer cast
passed me in the street I think I'd
still be talking about it 30 years later
you know what I mean my wife yeah when
Indiana Jones was getting filmed over
here she's seen Harrison Ford she hasn't
stopped talking about it so I think if I
seen Josh Hartnett walking down the
street I'd be like you know this is five
years ago the other day I don't know why
I've aged that much in five years but
five years ago the day
Josh Hartman was walking down that
street right there and you just think
about like how have they how has it only
cost that much when you look at how much
Blue Beetle is I just can't get my head
around here and CGI CGI must cost so
much money because I just don't get it
like again no offense to the cast
um and it's not even three hours long
either
it's just it doesn't make sense
are also built like it's new new IMAX
cameras for the black and white they had
to build a new thing to make their movie
happen uh it's it is crazy how
how Blue Beetle costs more than that
yeah and one thing that Christopher
Nolan does in a lot of his films is
he'll have cut away shots to like
something that's on screen for like
three or four seconds just adding
context to it he does it a lot
um
and but filming that shot takes you know
that takes money but you'll do it so
often in films where they just cut away
to something
and it's like three hours of content
there that there's a lot going on with
the film
um and I just I don't get how it's that
ex like it it costs either as much or
less than Blue Beetle
um and yeah they need to sort their
lives out can they go a fraction of you
know a third of the uh Indiana Jones
cost and it's crazy uh can I go over uh
the Oppenheimer results and there's not
as many facts for as there were for
Barbie so I will not spend as much time
uh Christopher Nolan's third highest
grossing opening weekend ever both
Global and domestic after the last two
Dark Knight movies the biggest Global
day and date opening weekend ever for a
biopic outpacking Bohemian Rhapsody
which has stars Rami Malik who's also in
this movie Beat passion to Christ yay
the biggest Global opening for a drama
since Creed
uh drama since 2019 uh ahead of creed 3.
uh the highest grossing opening weekend
for an R-rated film beating out John
Wick chapter four my other favorite
movie of the year biggest IMAX opening
for Christopher Nolan which is crazy to
hear and biggest iMacs for a universal
title in U.S and Canada uh it's cool how
it wasn't the biggest opening but
biggest opening IMAX for no one he
really is the the name associated with
it third biggest international box
office opening for a Nolan film in like
for likes behind dark knight rises in
Dark Knight and uh the biggest
non-superhero opening for Nolan
obviously and the biggest opening day
for a Nolan film in 33 markets as
including Saudi Arabia India Netherlands
Argentina and Belgium so this movie is
doing really really well and I'm happy
to see it because both you and I uh Paul
and I I usually see the movies before
Paul
and I'll give my opinion and then Paul
usually comes back with a different
opinion than myself and this is the
first time in a long time where as I
told him I loved it and that and then he
came back and he loved it too and I was
like we finally agree we're on the same
page we don't have any any
differentiating qualms about it so yeah
I'm really happy I don't agree with you
laughing at Passion of the Christ before
Greg I noticed you did a little yay when
you said he'd be crushing hey I've saw a
passion of Christ twice in the theaters
man I gave my money I gave my money but
uh you better pay again otherwise you go
into Health now I am I I just thought it
was a master class in editing I really
did I thought um just from the beginning
right from the off the way that Nolan
spliced things together you know you got
the idea of what was going on in Upper
oppenheimer's head
I think if you didn't know the back
story like his entire life it might have
been a bit difficult to follow but
and knowing someone who's well versed in
history of course I I followed it really
well I thought they laid out the you
know the certain segments of his life in
a really good order as well it's it's
just classic Nolan where he's not
telling the story chronologically but
he's laying things out in events that
kind of build and flow really well
together to give it almost this like
Locomotion feel
um and even the score itself it's kind
of like it's almost like a train like
powering away in the background like
and you know you have moments where they
cut to people's feet tapping and
clickings the countdown before they set
off the Trinity test there's just lots
of things in the background where it's
constantly feels like it's building
towards something
um and yeah the whole just the ending of
the movie as well brilliant built right
up the beginning where you've got uh
Oppenheimer looking at puddles and
raindrops falling in it and then they
close out the film with them staring at
the pond watching the raindrops fall in
that and then imagining it it's like
it's it's so well put together that the
whole film's like a chain reaction I
feel it starts off with a little thing
and then you know lots of crazy Dynam
Dynamic things happen throughout the
movie that will build towards this big
realization at the end that he might be
the destroyer of worlds because he's set
off something in motion that's probably
not going to get stopped everyone's
gonna get their hands on the bomb
eventually they're going to build
hydrogen bombs they're gonna have to
build more bigger bombs because of the
the hydrogen bomb and it's just gonna
sell this chain of escalation that could
possibly lead to the end of the world
um and I thought even today I was kind
of I'm making a perfect scene video for
the ending and just thinking about how
some of the characters were used as well
stross is a really really good inclusion
because I've realized that he sort of
represents Russia
so he sees these you know two people off
in the corner talking away and then gets
paranoid because he doesn't know what
they're talking about and this causes
him to almost strike from the dark and
put his own plans in place and I was
thinking you know that that's a lot how
Russia acted they saw the nuke was
getting developed off in this country
that you know was their friend at one
point but that they wouldn't acknowledge
them when it came to that and so what
they started doing is using their own
tactics like Espionage
um and stuff like that to to basically
get the secrets of how to build a nuke
and just seeing how like characters are
used like that it's just such a a Next
Level take on something and but Nolan to
have written and directed this it's it's
absolutely insane the guys the guys next
level I think he created an epic
haunting harrowing drama you know I uh
you saw this in IMAX I'm assuming yeah
yeah
um is it I don't know what the screen
size of yours is I saw it at the
universal IMAX which I really wanted to
do because that's where Nolan tests his
movies no that's right he even he even
had a thing where he was like here's the
perfect seat I did I sat one row behind
the perfect I missed I missed the
perfect seat
it was already taken but the but I have
seen every Nolan film in IMAX since the
Dark Knight I saw Dark Knight like nine
or ten times in IMAX because I was just
obsessed with it it was the first one to
really use that translation and I
thought that his usage of it was done in
such a unique way because
normally when you when you do the scenes
with the iMac shots they're they're used
for like the grand scenes the you know
the the big action scenes or whatever
you know and here there were so many
just
character-driven dialogue driven scenes
where he would use of course he used it
for the the spectacle moments the cool
space particles whatever whatever it may
be
he used it for those moments but I loved
how he's become such a master at his
craft with understanding IMAX to the
point where he was just using so much to
create a better more intimate film for
this drama scenes that were just
dialogue moments and knowing when to use
those iMac shots to immerse you even
more it has this effect to me he he's
better at what 3D hopes to achieve you
know with rodrigi wants to put you in
the movie 3D wants to immerse you into
it he knows how to do it without 3D
glasses and that experience of being
thrusted into the perspective of
Oppenheimer because you know when it's
it cuts between being in color the two
timelines with him being with it being
in color which is more of this
subjective point of view through
oppenheimer's perspective and then you
have the Black and White Version which
is not a subjective of a point of view
that's more from Louis strauss's
perspective
knowing how to intertwine with those I
remember like watching Dunkirk and I
didn't quite catch on to that right away
and I think a lot of people didn't
understand the timeline Grant he's going
to be doing a million more timelines
there I thought his usage here was
excellent and I and I loved the approach
of because I was thinking to myself
before watching it you know like it's a
three hour film
everyone's talking about this being an
IMAX experience I don't think they're
going to show the events of Hiroshima
obviously have heard about the the
nuclear test that they would be showing
here in the film like is that the only
exciting part of this movie that we're
gonna see on screen of the spectacle is
is just this one the one explosion and
what I thought he did so well especially
from talking about quantum physics of
how energy is is such a is so physic
energy is physical that's a big part of
of quantum physics that it is a physical
thing
and when you're in oppenheimer's mindset
of watching him the way he visualizes
atoms the way he visualizes particles
the way he visualizes the Stars it's
just something that you don't see on
screen and you're watching literally the
the the I mean like the Law of
Attraction and the law of action into
place where you're hopping into his
mindset and you're you're seeing how he
sees things and you're watching the
creation of that manifest which is in
and of itself quantum physics uh the way
he is portraying Oppenheimer like he is
the embodiment of quantum physics which
is such a radical way of Science and
thinking back then and you're watching
that come to fruition and of course like
The Haunting themes of
this was going to happen you know like
that was the whole thing they were
trying to beat was that the Nazis are
going to be they're going to be trying
to develop this themselves like they
needed to to create this and
one of my favorite one of my favorite
things about it was obviously it starts
off with a man with good intentions you
know and you see how him being Jewish
and what's happening in World War II how
effective he is by this he kept it so
character driven
and by the time the bomb is created one
of the one of the most Eerie moments to
me which I don't really see being talked
about is
what he's waiting around for or the the
call about the Hiroshima he's waiting
for the call about the bomb and he's not
being informed and he he finally gets
Matt Damon on the line and he's asking
him
you know about being there about get
like wanting to be be present for Stuff
and Matt Damon's just like
why he just like throws him away like
you're not needed anymore and this was
the warning sign he was receiving the
entire film that there's going to come a
point in time where they're not going to
need you anyway they need you until they
don't
and that is so much of the Journey of
what he goes on of being needed and
being so he's such an important figure
and all he's been known as you know the
creator of of the story of Worlds right
and and you see that obviously that
wasn't his intent nor is it exactly a
movie where you're just like oh I feel
sorry for Oppenheimer because he's he's
aware of the fact that this he needed to
create this this was going to happen
this needed to happen at the same time
he's aware of what he has created and
like you said I love what you said about
it being a chain reaction because that
is that it what that was the warning
sign he was getting the entire movie
this Progressive uh chain reaction that
kept happening and of course this chain
reaction was bound to happen so yeah
it's it's to me it's it's an unsettling
film but damn it's it's also like
beautiful and and a great cautionary
tale and I think especially for the
warning times of what Ai and the
capability of what AI is it also still
feels timely you know uh for what for
what's going on in our current state
it's a very different type of subject
but you know same things like AI is
bound to happen uh but there is a way
where this can really get ahead of
ourselves and it can get out of hand and
it could be used as a dominant force
that could ultimately uh set Humanity in
a darker Direction so yeah I loved it
man I thought it was brilliant
yeah just just thinking about like how
he he goes from this massive personality
that everyone wants to follow like he
he's part of the Communist Party well
he's not part of it but you know he
moves in those circles but everyone's
enamored with him like women and
everything and then he starts talking
about the teachers union and throwing
like he's talking on pedestals and stuff
and people are really looking up to him
and then that translates over to the uh
Los Alamos desert and you know he feels
like he's in control of Everything But
as soon as he as soon as that test is
successful just completely cut out
um and he can almost feel like the
remorse like oh crap I've built
something that people can now replicate
I can no longer control how it's used
um and even like Hitler at the the point
at that point had died
and then they were just kind of like
well you know Japan haven't surrendered
yet let's go and drop the bomb and it's
like he has no saying that at all he
doesn't get to decide if they drop it
once if they drop it twice if they're
going to use it in future warfare if the
Soviets get their hands on it you know
once you've invented it and and it's out
there
it's everyone's and he no longer can
control it no matter what even saying
you know we we shouldn't build hydrogen
bombs the government ostracized them and
throw them on on try they say it's not a
trial but he gets put on a hearing m is
security clearance is stripped he gets
almost branded a trait air and and all
that for just saying look guys be
careful I I think we should put things
in place to stop us building nukes and
it's insane like just that shot at the
end you just feel the regret and the
worry and the anxiety and almost the
kind of like oh crap what have I done it
I think it's just so I really can't wait
to re-watch it and there's so many
things going on with it automatically
the auditorium when he's giving
it's like the social anxiety moment yeah
where he's giving this uh big he's
giving this speech and it's almost like
propaganda in a way and everyone's like
cheering but he's all he can see is the
horror and I love this shot where the
wrecked focus on him and behind him it's
just like it's shaking uh and and then
seeing the the horrors of how he's
witnessed like he just can't stop
thinking about what he's done to just
people you know yeah I thought that was
an excellent moment as well to Dem there
are some people who who I've seen are
like oh I wish we saw the Hiroshima
bombing moment
um I don't really know exactly what the
desire is to have seen it is if it's for
to to Really drive home the emotional
affect or is it for wanting to see a
spectacle of horror I don't really know
what it is that people really want uh
from wanting to see that I think the way
they decided to do it here was
for me at least was just as effective
because they kept it intimate for seeing
its own Creator being so affected by the
disaster that he has created and seeing
the like a like the disillusionment of
how the government treated him too
it's brilliant and the performances are
so good from everyone here I love how
it's like a cameo Fest it's more than
the flash right like it's just it's just
not every like 10 minutes there would be
like hey you're about to beat and then
here's a new famous person I didn't even
realize what the entire cast list was I
only knew of a few names so I was
constantly being surprised by who kept
showing up on screen and even if they
were there for a tiny bit even if they
didn't have like one scene or whatever
they were always so effective they were
always they everyone made an impression
everyone made an impact uh Robert Downey
Jr I think gave some of his best work in
years and especially for the it doesn't
take much work to start looking past the
fact that it's Robert Downey Jr you know
like I thought he really immersed
himself into that role and I loved um I
love Matt Damon in it Josh Hartnett
between Black Mirror and this I think
he's really repositioned himself to
getting a lot more work again to being
like a great dramatic because he's so
good here too and he was so good in that
black mirror episode as well uh the
safety bro remember which safety brother
it was uh I forget which one but he's
awesome
and uh freaking Jason Clark as this
aggressive ass anything Benny safety
yeah everyone was so goddamn good and I
loved um I loved Emily Blunt towards the
end and in the beginning I had issues
with the way the the movie wrote the
women because they just kind of showed
up to be like the Press complaining
crying but then but towards the last
half of the movie I thought Emily Blunt
like the way her character was portrayed
I thought she did this she had one of
the best moments to me and when she was
being interrogated and she was she was
she she gave us like kind of a cathartic
experience of what she's like pining for
like Oppenheimer stand up fight back
stand up fight back Robert come on and
the way she handled that scene I thought
was so good too everyone was so freaking
good my only little qualm
and I didn't hear anything about this
and I saw that some people are feeling
this way it might it doesn't take up a
lot of the movie so it's not a big deal
to me my only little qualm and I want to
be careful of my words here to make sure
we don't uh affect monetization on this
video is the the way sexuality was
handled in certain scenes and that was
the one part like it's one of those
cases where I'm I have a bit of a
dichotomy about it because I understand
the context very well of course the
context I'm not going to be here and say
it wasn't necessary to have that because
it is such an integral part of
oppenheimer's story
and the idea too of like the the
beginning of the the two greatest sins
in a way with Florence Pugh when he
first sleeps with her or the quote
slips it in yeah I didn't agree with him
doing that I'll never look at that quote
in the same way again I'm slipping it in
as he says that but it's vid on the nose
and it's a it's a it kind of registered
as a little silly to me and and then
even the one in the interrogation room
where you're seeing it from Emily one's
perspective
like I got it I I'm not gonna say I
didn't get it I just thought the
execution of it was not it wasn't ugly
it wasn't it wasn't exactly distasteful
it just registered as a little corny to
me it register is a little cheesy in the
way it was handled and I thought that
needed a little bit more TLC in order to
make it more effective and not like it
would pull me out rather than pull me
more in if that makes sense
um yeah so yeah that was the only part
of it but it doesn't take up a lot of
the movie but other than that I I
thought the movie if you just let it
wash over you because I know some people
have a hard time adjusting to the
editing of the film because it does move
really fast uh but if you just kind of
surrender to the experience I I thought
I I thought it was a really fast moving
three hours people have issues with the
last 40 minutes of the film of feeling
like we didn't really need all that
course of like I think that's such a
necessary part of them that part of the
story is so important and that is such
an important part I thought it was
totally necessary
yeah I mean going back to what you said
before about people saying we needed to
see hiroshiman or Hiroshima
um I don't think we did I think you know
you you don't there's lots of things
that you don't actually see in this
movie for example you don't see the
Soviets trying to steal the bomb you
don't see the Nazis you encounter
Heisenberg at the start but once you
know he's off making the bomb for the
Germans you don't see him again you know
it's not framed like a sort of they're
racing against each other
um it's all shown from From
oppenheimer's perspective and I think
that's why they didn't show Hiroshima
because
if you had him going like well what
happened and then you cut to it and you
see it happens it kind of almost robs
the character a bit because he's just
completely shut out I don't feel like
you would have that feeling he was shut
out if you actually saw it happen I
think he'd be like well we we know what
happened there but even as an audience
we're kind of out to it and we're
just getting told very manner of like
very very matter of fact here's exactly
what happened they dropped the bomb
three days later they dropped another
bomb that's it you're out of the picture
he's like I've got blood on my hands
it's like oh whatever shut up you cry
baby just get out he's completely
dismissed and I think showing that would
have probably you know you didn't need
it
um I think just keeping it purely on
oppenheimer's perspective that was the
smartest way to go about it because and
be and what I've seen on Twitter was
people crying you know the the
representations missing for Japanese
people but
like is it good representation to just
have loads of Japanese people getting
killed and I feel like the criticism
there would have been oh Christopher
Nolan he's a white man he casts nothing
but white people in his films and the
only time he has you know an Asian
person in this film they're getting
killed and I think just not showing it
was the best way to go about it I think
either way he's going to get criticized
and the smarter move was to just keep
things solely rooted in oppenheimer's
perspective
not have you know the horror of it and
have it more being an imagined one where
he's sort of EX and even in the
auditorium I I think that gives the
feeling enough you know what I mean
where you see the bright flash of light
people's skin melting away and then he
ends up walking through and stepping on
that body and then outside he's seeing
people being sick who weren't you know
immediately affected by the blast and
that to me is a lot more subtle
keeps things rooted in the perspective
and then you haven't got the whole big
thing of like oh it's so gory seeing
that nuke on screen like we've seen
nukes enough
um and I just don't feel they needed it
now speaking of nukes what did you think
of the the actual bomb that they've been
hyping up for months now as being like
they made a real nuke and fired it off
I think some people wanted it to be
bigger or something I don't know exactly
what people wanted I wanted it to be
wider yeah I think people really wanted
the mushroom cloud effect you know I
think that's what people really wanted
I thought the sequence though itself was
so
it was so impactful like the the the the
the way the sound the sound design of
that moment to uh like like this movie
has
this jarring sound effect design
um in certain moments where it's almost
like jump scary you know uh what it it's
it's done to enhance the uh the idea of
like perspective with Oppenheimer
especially of being lost in his own
world and then being brought back to
reality you know and I thought that
moment too where the way they took out
some sound and then that bang were the
after effective when the oh the winds
started blowing through everyone and I
thought the way that sequence was done
like the build up to it of whether or
not I'll go wrong like that whole line
because it's in the trailer and uh I
thought it was so much better here in
the actual movie itself of of the less
than a zero percent close to us almost a
zero percent chance that the that
they'll rip a hole in the atmosphere you
know that they could destroy the world
of guy you know you want it to be at
zero but it just puts you in that in
that moment of
what a decision you gotta make you know
like you might you might not just kill
everyone here you might end the world
right now uh and like how to make that
decision is so terrifying so I thought
the build up to it was awesome I thought
it still looked gorgeous on screen and
maybe if it did go bigger it could have
driven home that effect of house because
you know we've seen so many explosions
and movies before we've seen so much of
that that maybe it didn't completely
drive home the effect of oh wow if they
really especially if you're if you're
uninitiated to understanding what any of
the atomic bomb hydrogen bomb if you
don't know anything about it maybe as a
newcomer to this you're not really
understanding just how powerful this is
based off the explosion that they do
show on screen
but I thought to cap the way they
captured the Flames is yeah you do want
that wider shot I understand from an
audience member but the the
connection to the flames and how close
those shots were again it was all to
capture it from Robert oppenheimer's
perspective and I thought that's why
those shots work so well so to me I was
really I was more than satisfied with
how it was done
of course there is that side of me I'm
like it would have been cool to see the
mushroom cloud that would have been cool
to see that full wide shot but I always
got YouTube to look it up
I think the issue with it was they put
like a lamp post in front of it to kind
of give it scale but the the actual like
stem of the explosion itself just looks
so skinny
um and for then to like knock people
back
I just I wouldn't I couldn't see that
happening yeah but might be wrong but
yeah just to me and the buildup was
incredible and then you had the silence
and then it was like a little far
and then everyone went flying probably
gonna get in the comments were
saying it was like a little fart but
that's just kind of how I felt but other
than that I love the movie glad to see
it's doing well and you know what it
looks like it's gonna do well for a long
time because I've been looking ahead to
the Future and there's like a lot of
iMac showings are completely sold out
for weeks and weeks and weeks yeah
someone posted
um a tweet before saying I managed to
book like the the only empty
um seat I could get for a 70 millimeter
showing of Oppenheimer and that was on
August 6th so you're looking at like
weeks in advance how they've got this
whole thing sold out and those are
premium tickets as well and yeah I think
it's gonna do really well I got my
tickets
um
many many weeks ago and it is several
weeks from now oh yeah yeah I did not it
it's out here in in Los Angeles it it
sold out IMAX
so fast so it's crazy because yeah they
did it was all that all that talk about
it taking up Mission Impossibles
um premiums which we did not talk about
it's box office dip but it did yeah pick
up the mission impossible screenings and
and uh it panned out because early on it
sold it's sold out like weeks in advance
all the weeks you know it's doing really
well it's gonna make it's gonna make a
lot of money and I think Nolan too is
you know the way how we redefined the
genre like when Batman Begins came out
everyone was like we need to do more
origin stories that are darker like
Batman Begins I I think in some way
people are going to try to do more
biopics now too I just feel like take
the right lessons from how it's done
please don't like take take the right
leg you know find find the find what why
or really understand why this works
before just going we need another
Oppenheimer movie we need another
Heisenberg yeah yeah what'd you think of
Gary Oldman man did you like this movie
did you think of Gary Oldman and um yeah
yeah he played um uh Churchill and it's
funny because it's the same yeah time
frame too he's got his own little
Cinematic Universe going on here
Kang it's like the king of biopics
I thought it was great I always think
he's really good yeah just blown away by
it uh probably not intended there loads
of people have said that over the last
couple of days anyway they've been like
Blown Away by oh and I'm sorry yeah it's
stupid but I've just said it now yeah
but yeah I really really enjoyed it
um I want to go see it again love
Christopher Nolan I am kind of teetering
on do I do a breakdown of this or is it
kind of a touchy subject but you know
great film really really glad that the
weekend's been good for cinemas as well
Cinemas packed Cinemas back
great work guys hope it's over it's done
you proved me wrong very happy to be
proven wrong on it
um glad that they're both doing well I
thought they were good I personally
thought they were going to eat each
other and I thought it was going to be
the I thought the conversation would be
having this week was they shouldn't have
released these on the same weekend
but you know the arguments there that
they might not have done as well if
they'd not been released on the same
weekend the cultural movement
everyone got involved everyone was happy
to go to the cinema and yeah I think uh
you know some people enjoyed the movie
some people didn't but
you know it's good to see Cinemas doing
well they they've had a tough time you
know there's a tough time coming with
the strikes and uh yeah I'm glad I'm
glad they've had this week I think we do
have to address before we end though
really quick is that
the one that maybe shouldn't have
released
is Mission Impossible dead reckoning
part one yeah maybe it it has dropped 64
percent
so it might not even make its money back
like this I mean it was an expensive
film it's kind of crazy yeah this was
the big concern I don't think anyone was
really it's crazy because the mission
impossible films have never none of them
have crossed a billion like there's they
throw so much money at them and they
make they they make money and they've
progressively made more money
um other than part three like part two
is still like I believe profit-wise
whatever is I think I might be wrong but
I think that is still one of the more
lucrative profits that they've ever had
um part three was the one that was a
little bit worrisome but this is the
dead reckoning part one is not doing
anywhere near as well as they hope even
if they match the even if it was just
the same budget as Fallout you know it
it it's still not doing it anywhere near
as well as they hoped
so I'm reading this stats here
um Mission Impossible dead reckoning
part one has crossed 200 million
overseas
um it gives it a 300 million Global
total and it was 55 million at the uh
the last weekend gone which gives it a
minus 64.6 second weekend drop
um so it's eyeing a 620 million to 670
million Global run which
yeah I mean I'm not sure of all the ins
and outs but it's
at least it's not a massive bomb it
might you know it's not going to turn a
big profit but
yeah just I think I purely think it was
just down to the bad release time redo I
thought it was a great film but no one's
talking about it anymore no I mean
especially to come like before Barbie
and Oppenheimer which are original
properties and they are making such a
there's there's such a conversation
piece whereas Mission Impossible dead
reckoning while a good film it is still
ultimately like
you know a good Mission Impossible
installment but it's not as anywhere
near The Conversation Piece as these
other two films are uh yeah
it's a bummer it's a bummer I always
want these movies to succeed I love the
franchise so much so hopefully oh Tommy
Cruz Tommy Cruz they knew this was
coming as well because he was a bit
annoyed that they were going to be
getting all the premium screens
so nothing you can do mate Bob and
Heimer taking out everyone mate taking
out everyone but uh yeah any final
thoughts nah man I can't wait for
Spider-Man 4 with Thomas Hayden Church
and Miles Morales I can't wait for that
confirmed we've confirmed it confirmed
it here forever confirmed in the title
with a question mark though uh
question mark yeah exactly
so yeah anything anything on the on the
horizon for you Greg uh no thanks man uh
we are good uh
I'm good I'm good man well did you send
me a message here
I just sent you some stats and a picture
of the the atom bomb
I didn't realize that but we'll pass
that now yeah yeah so if you've been
paying attention to the the breakdown
Community you might have seen
um that Mt was sadly let go at New Rock
Stars last week I had a word with a guy
um he's gonna do some stuff for us so
yeah keep an eye out keep an eye out for
that really excited to see you um
he's got Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
breakdown coming out so yeah I'm excited
to see what Harry did I'm excited I'm
excited for that man empty is a is a
true Talent
all right man what's gonna embarrass me
yeah yeah yeah brother all right man I'm
ready to I'm ready to I'm ready to close
out now
me too thanks for supporting us guys
thank you forgot to like subscribe love
yours